Wow, where to begin?
Alright, in case you missed it, I was off
the grid for an entire month, and I have the
facial hair to prove it...my beard even has
a Twitter account already, yes really.
Over the past 30 days, I've had no phone,
no email, no Twitter and no digital noise
in my life.
I also didn't watch any news or have one single
conversation about politics the entire time
I was gone.
What I did do during this time was a combination
of writing my book, relaxing, some gardening,
taking long walks with my dog and spending
time with friends and family.
As I said in our livestream yesterday, I'm
incredibly grateful and humbled by those of
you who support The Rubin Report on Patreon
and PayPal for letting me and my crew carve
out this precious bit of time to rest, rejuvenate
and come back more focused than ever.
I learned a few life lessons in this last
month, including writing a book is far more
intense and introspective than you can possibly
imagine...
so just give me a little more time to work
on it.
Unsurprisingly, the news cycle kept on spinning
without me, and I'm just now catching up on
everything I missed.
From the terror attack in Barcelona, to the
events in Charleston to devastation of Hurricane
Harvey and now Trumps reversal of DACA, there's
no shortage of news for me to catch up on.
For this Direct Message though, I want to
look forward not backwards, and instead share
some thoughts on the future of what we're
going to be doing around here.
I consider today to be the first episode of
season 3 of The Rubin Report.
Our first season of The Rubin Report as an
interview show began two years ago when we
launched on Ora TV with my interview with
Sam Harris.
Over the next year the show began to blow
up as we focused more and more on free speech
and the battle for logic and reason to be
put back into public discourse.
About a year ago, we left Ora and went fully
independent so we could 100% control the content
we were creating as well as the business behind
it -- I consider this phase of our show to
be Season 2.
I don't know if any show out there has a more
diverse guest list over the past two years
and I intended on expanding on it, going deeper
on the important issues more than ever before.
Your support allows me to do what I think
is right, instead of focusing on what content
will make a dime.
Whether YouTube demonetizes us, or the algorithms
work against us because of the dangerous "controversial"
topics we cover, The Rubin Report will continue
to cover the issues that really matter, having
the detailed, nuanced conversations you'll
never get on mainstream news.
With this in mind, I'm thrilled to be launching
season 3 of The Rubin Report with one of the
few people I find consistently making some
sense of the endless noise that we are constantly
bombarded with.
Phil Defranco, host of the aptly titled Philip
Defranco Show is one of the guys I turn to
to get unbiased, sourced, and credible analysis
of current events.
As one of the first big YouTubers around he's
had an interesting personal and political
evolution himself, something he's done in
front of the camera for years now.
Our friends at Learn Liberty are partnering
with us for this episode and Phil has requested
that his honorarium for this show be given
to the Polycystic Disease Foundation, a cause
which is very personal to him.
After the show Learn Liberty will be writing
a check of $1,500 dollars to the foundation
-- you can find out more about this cause
at PKD cure dot org.
Alright, I'm back, bearded and ready to talk
about the important issues of the day.
If there's a specific issue you want us to
cover or a special person you want us to talk
to this season let us know in the comments
right down below.
Since I've been off the Internet for awhile
I assume all YouTube comments are positive
and friendly now, so I look forward to seeing
what you come up with...